[Music]
hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to Garden the band band 2.
the sequel to Garden of ban ban 1 which
is a game about the garden of ban ban
whatever the hell that is I don't really
know it seems like some kind of an
elementary school or a preschool or
something like that
it's not really a school it's more like
a daycare but it's not right it's like a
Chuck E cheese where you stay forever
it's like if Chuck E cheese was a prison
but also very drably decorated
and not fun at all for a parent looking
for their missing child time is a
delicate matter click the clock to
advance time
oh
um
[Music]
did I actually
I don't know what's happening here
okay
I don't know why people were stealing
the tables seemed unnecessary
I know you're looking for your kid and
all that but
oh
okay
hello
you're missing a very important tool
oh
[Music]
I saw you and then I fell down and then
I went for a bit of a tumble
well look at you did you punch me did
you who did you punch who did you punch
so hard that they turned into a fine
spray of blood
why are you so veiny I don't like that
just for that drone thing
all right
hello
oh
hi I'm here for
an inspection I don't even remember why
I came here in the first place I'm sure
I had my reasons and I'm sure they were
good and I'm sure you're gonna give me
exactly what I came looking for
oh what
[Music]
how do you explain that one
what do you mean medical sector
what kind of kindergarten is this
well I don't have that
oh I have that
wow
this is it the things we've done have
finally come back to bite us everyone's
gone and The Whispers from the abyss
just keep getting louder I think I even
saw a face or two looking up at me we
were told everything that gets thrown
into the abyss dies but appears we were
tricked if you're reading this take my
advice and leave everything here should
be forgotten and erased from history
well
how many things are you trying to kill
that you just want to constantly throw
things into a pit
because I don't know if the abyss should
work like that
I don't know if that's a good thing
what is this testing sector
I'm sure it is
that sounds good to me
don't need to tell me twice you tell me
to test things my portal instincts kick
in and I just want to be
there and test and nope
I guess not
yeah so what I heard from that note is
if I go into the abyss I don't die
well that's not how I expected that to
move
sure
let's go to the com sector
the spider is real
okay well at least I know where the
tables went there is an elevator to
success but stairs are good exercise
what the spider is real and it's coming
I don't know if I need to know that
so what spider and how real we talking
because nothing here seems to be real
there it is
it's a kindergarten I knew something
like that
that's what Garten of ban ban means
customer registration recap board Drew
for waverley's 22
hmm
you're expected to punch in from lowest
to greatest
okay I don't know what you mean by punch
in but I'm assuming that's some kind of
code
can I have these
is this important does no door any open
at all
assume I have good grammar everyone just
assume that
hi
hey you there I I can see on the cameras
okay I am so happy to see you and I need
your help with something you got it can
you even hear me hello
listen if you can hear what I'm saying
wave at any camera
oh yeah
I don't know how to wave
huh
wave
all right good
oh thank God I'm so glad you're here I
thought this was the end
I was looking around and walked into the
security room then the door closed
behind me and I've been stuck inside
since it needs a light blue key card to
open but I don't have it
I know why you're here and I can help
you but you've got to get me out of here
if I recall correctly uh only
maintenance workers have the light blue
key card so you're gonna have to go down
to the maintenance room and look there
the door there is probably locked as
well and I can open it from here but I
do have control over the break room door
here I open it for you see if you can
find anything useful in there okay but
also I don't even know why I'm here hey
wait it's this place I remember this
from before
oh
my antenna
feel an old friend is waiting in the art
I don't know if I have any friends
to use my toy
all right right that dude yeah an old
friend
okay teleport the toy to the nearest
room yeah I'll do just that
in just a moment hello
case update report number six
communication with k6 has provided
invaluable information that may explain
why previous cases have sorely failed as
well as improve the creation of future
cases despite being seemingly incredibly
intelligent with the good old drones
I lost mine a couple of weeks ago
maintenance workers use them for all
sorts of things like reaching high
places and grabbing things that fell
into the abyss and sometimes
[Music]
if you need my insight
okay thanks
anyway a meeting between k6 and the
human genome donor
this is oh it's a sperm donor k-6
describes a constant immense pain that
is present in the entirety of its body
despite the human genome donor of k6
being a doctor the case has failed to
give a description more detailed than
the pain having to do with the blood
flow k6 has no blood in their systems
only gervanium
Alias the devil talking about bendy is
this a bendy thing
there's something about bendy meet the
family
and also the spider slow Celine jumbo
Josh
opila bird Captain fiddles Stinger Flynn
Sheriff toadster
okie dokie then so now that I have this
thing I could probably go back to the
other rooms
and I still can't sound the emergency
alarm I still can't eat that cake and I
still haven't met this spider
whatever it is
so what did you do I don't even know
what that did that open this or
something
[Music]
so that did something I just don't know
what it did so there's got to be
oh wait don't have a pink one
nope never mind
what color do I have I thought I had
pink
huh
well
oh
ah it's a puzzle so do these have names
on them or am I just gonna guess
randomly because I bet it ties into the
information over there
okay so red ah okay
so I need to go from lowest to highest
but they do showcase who's where on that
board so three
then it would be four
yep okay four six
yep
then 7 9 and 10.
and 10 and then
HH
and Beverly
done I did it what did I do
I don't know what I did
what did I do oh
I see oh hi
cool I have a yellow
yeah
[Music]
uh-huh yeah I know I know remember
you're looking for a light blue key card
good luck thank you it's okay to have no
friends be miserable like me well what
if I don't want to treat others how you
would like to be treated with respect
what if I go
I may be slow but I'm quick to help
anyone in need I doubt that gonna be
slow to save my life
well
working groups no smaller than two carry
flashlights at all times flashlights are
in the equipment room if indirect
confrontation with a spider causes much
noise as possible until help arrives
what
all right let's see what happens I guess
la la
it's awfully quiet
almost concerning you know am I supposed
to be memorizing these arrows I I really
didn't so I wasn't even paying attention
to him so I'm not I'm not going to be
able to recite that if that was supposed
to be a memory trick of some kind oh no
okay so pink equals left and blue equals
right
ah pink equals the go the opposite way
I see blue equals go that direction okay
so that's perfect
okay that's good to know
I don't know exactly why I need to know
that but I know that now
I have a tape
then
oh yellow glass is a breakable material
the toy cannot be directly pointed at it
uh
oh
I said go
nice
[Music]
uh-huh
hey look at that well that was nice
um
so
downstairs I'm guessing
ah thank you boo wow wow that is
terrifying hey look at that though wow
that was easy
is this light blue it doesn't look like
blue okay
oh no
oh no oh no oh my God
foreign
[Music]
and where are you putting me oh good
right here great okay so I know the way
to go for this I think wait I didn't get
the thing I think
how about I grab this
okay so opposite of pink go with the
blue opposite of pink oh God oh God oh
God oh God go with the blue easy
easy it's definitely not directly above
me go with the blue opposite of pink
relatively simple
behind me I can't see anything is it
there I can't tell
well that was easy
sock eggs nerd whoa
why did that happen
I forgot to make as much noise as
possible I should have been screaming at
the top of my lungs that entire time but
I didn't because I'm an idiot anyway I
did that I don't I don't know why but I
think I got the light blue key card you
in here
hello
Hi friend
that's weird
why aren't you here
oh three birds with one stone I'll get
all of your key cards I'll get the
perfect specimen and I don't have to
deal with that thing down there
and it's all thanks to you you calling
me the perfect
that hard
or maybe I I did either way it's best
you take an apple I prepare for our
little surgery surgery huh I am the
perfect specimen after all but uh I'm
afraid I'm not for sale or taking
stealing I'm not for seal for steel
what are you doing to me
hey what's up little buddy
[Music]
oh okay
so is this how the the genetic donor
definitely not
anything untoward uh was a doctor and so
it knows how to do surgery because of
that is that what I'm supposed to get hi
buddy how you doing is that a button
over there
oh I see
how about that
yes please
uh well all right go around
yeah yeah
uh-huh
[Music]
hello what did that do
can you go over there is that a thing
you can do oh wow
how about there
oh I'm getting it I understand so that's
what it wants me to try to do so that's
how it can break the glass because then
I do it over there and it's going to
come back around well
didn't go quite far enough
no don't go to yourself go to the x
there we go
no what are you doing you okay
now there
nice
excellent
cool
hey what what is it is
[Music]
that the genetic donation
okay don't look at that particular thing
okay why you yellow
why was I on a cot
I don't understand what you want from me
oh card
there it is
all right perfect
and that does what exactly
huh
oh oh oh
fascinating okay well I didn't have a
good experience the last time I went on
one of these
um
but all right
bye buddy
I'm going up to the sky to the heavens
above to the place where I belong as the
perfect specimen that I am
you understand don't you of course you
do
you do of course you do
you always understand me
so you got these really nice trees and
then you're trying to tell me that those
are supposed to be Birds
oh there's a bunch of squiggly M's your
butts or boobs
and you got these nice trees
do not cross it will
charge
charge hit it in the eye
what is that
it will trick me it'll whoa
please tell me that's your hand please
tell me that's your arm
[Music]
poke it in the eye
oh oh I see well before I do that let me
what
hello is that a cannon
is that an ancient 18th century Naval
Cannon
I'm sorry what
oh boy
or I'll be with you in a moment
don't mind me oh bro go bro
okay
hi oh
child Babel Fish elephant
you dropped this can I use this for a
cannonball
hmm
I
[Music]
it's a gun no it's a syringe where where
did I even see that that was a gun
thinking Canon I have blood
why do I have blood what's this oh
I'm collecting it
why
I don't know
I'm sure I'll find out oh distract
before extraction
uh
uh well
all right then
again I don't know why
okay I can collect multiple at a time
that's useful
and then I will need to obtain uses
and I can do that by doing this
get him
get get him
yeah
what what hey you don't
know you're bald
you were so eyeballed
I don't like where this spelling is
going
okay now I'm really gonna make sure
unless there is something about this
cannon that I need to do but I don't
think there is
I think it's just that I gotta blast the
damn thing get them
I said get him
who can I get you okay I did it all
right I just need to wait like half a
second longer
but also why am I doing this I don't
even have no idea
huh oh
[Music]
I feel like they're using the eyeball on
the ground as a cannonball was a much
better idea
all right fine this is less exciting
oh goodbye
huh
are you dead for good
are you for good dad better be oh
I don't know why I have that that seems
odd
well I'm not gonna think about it too
much
I
bye
hi oh all right perfect
you still there buddy
all right also why was that one gigantic
is there some deep lore relating to its
size
I will never have an answer and that's
okay
because I don't want it
hello where am I
uh oh ah
interesting oh ah interesting oh
interesting
uh-huh
yeah that's fine
that's fine that that's good
like that
I don't know what's going on back here
I'm gonna go back oh
oh
that thing does not bode well
oh good
well you're not here anymore or you are
here lurking in the shadows and I simply
cannot see you
either way I don't want to be there
anymore okay
what is you
what is
why is you go my goodness
well I'm sure that'll get no explanation
not that it needs one
it simply is
hello buddy
should have done it the other way around
[Music]
all right whatever that did is probably
good
okay
case 10 the bird after the recent
genetic modifications that were applied
to case 10 significant behavioral
changes have been observed aggression
towards certain demographics
has been completely replaced with
protective and motherly Behavior said
demographics include individuals of
small stature high-pitched voices and
those with childlike attributes
children individuals that do not fall
into said demographics are still met
with extreme aggression that can turn
lethal due to the case's large size and
possession of a very sharp beak oddly
said demographics are almost exclusively
human
with exception of case 10A 10B 10c 10d
10e and 10f all organic organisms Birds
included both adult and young are met
with the same level of aggression as
humans who do not possess children
related attributes case is not ready for
presentation who are you presenting to
I don't know
I don't want to know
uh-huh
hat
[Applause]
best game 10 out of 10. best game best
game ever best best game best game
100 best game incredible game
phenomenal phenomenal phenomenal
phenomenal game
what am I doing here I don't even I
don't even know anymore did I push all
the buttons did I do all the things ah
here we go
awesome that is a garish red I do not
think that looks good but I'm gonna go
with it anyway because honestly
I can't be bothered to customize this
looks deadly
I'm sure nothing bad will happen to me
I'm sure that nothing bad oh
oh okay
all right good
oh well I guess I don't have my things
anymore
um
well
oh you're far away
no damn that was some speed
[Music]
all right
uh
um
I'm coming for you
oh God that really is death I thought it
was going to like the lights were going
to turn on and then it was going to be
like a boo but that was just death okay
all right that's moderately better so
what am I supposed to do about this oh
God
oh my God
oh my God oh my God it's the board get
it get it buddy
right
well that was easy thank you
kindness betrayal evil sadness kindness
betrayal sadness evil betrayal sadness
evil betrayal okay I hate
you
uh
oh cool everyone I want you all to
welcome our newest student you're late
to class
slide this time since this is your first
day but be late again and I'll repeat a
pieces
your new and unpopular student so you
will have to sit with the unpopular
table in the middle
now sit so we can begin
oh okay look at these cool basketballs
ah make me
bon bon where do you think
I was
ill-prepared for what you were about to
do
just random letters I don't know not 100
sure about it now sit so we can begin
okie dokie then I'm sitting
it's math
over the course of the semester you will
learn how to annihilate others how to
safely extract the human brain for
eating and oh wait I made a mistake I
think that's Lesson Four of the day
for math over the course of the semester
you will learn to add subtract divide
multiply and so much more I am so
excited
before we start let's revise some of the
basics what is six eight seven four one
two three six one two plus nine eight
one nine three nine nine one two and
remember wrong answers will be very
harshly punished
really smart kid
zero six three five two four
you kids are really paying attention
today yep next question and one that I
wrote myself uh-huh what is two plus two
frog well wrong well well it's a
four-letter word
you're getting out of here what is two
plus two
correct
wow I thought everyone would get it
wrong
uh-huh
before your lunch break uh-huh what is
misery plus disappointment
my life correct hmm
unfortunately that's all the time we
have for math for the day oh
go to your lunch break and then we'll
start the next lesson when you come back
okay sounds good thank you I don't know
what I'm supposed to be doing for love
oh
ah I get it we're the cool kids and we
chew gum get us
gum for money
who's gum
take gum you want gum I give gum
you okay oh
so sad
anybody got more please save our friend
he's getting bullied over there you want
to save this twerp give us your lunch
money oh
well this seems like a perfectly
reasonable exchange I can figure this
out here you go here's some gum
I'll take that yoink
uh and then here take that and I'll take
him and put in there perfect
all things are I'm cool now
I'm cool now
attention everyone this announcement
concludes your lunch break please return
to your classes okay also teachers
please keep in mind that we're on the
lookout for a very very naughty student
believed to be accompanied by a drone if
you catch them call principal ban bans
office immediately
okay
hi hello the person they're talking
about did you nope what am I saying
I said cool kids
unpopular kids like them yeah you can
see with the cool kids where you belong
okay
hi okay hello the next lesson is science
uh-huh I think we did for Math and since
this is the first science lesson of the
semester it will only be a review lesson
uh-huh but first let me introduce you to
our classroom rules okay no eating no
talking no breathing no moving no asking
questions and no washroom breaks
remember I will have to punish you very
very harshly if you break any of those
rules
back to their view let's start with
something easy how hot is the Sun
um
oh God wrong no well it's I didn't know
I thought the sea life lover might have
been on the beach a bit but I don't know
how hot is the sun I bet it's loud kid
because it's probably just gonna be
screaming
you know I thought that would have been
the right answer I I was pretty sure
what
I was pretty sure how hot is the Sun
It's gotta be popular kid I guess
nothing's as hot as me
[Laughter]
I'm allow it but only because it made me
laugh and because you're a cool kid I
can tell by your very cool glasses
next question
any hearts does an octopus have
uh
so funny God damn it wrong how what was
it supposed to be screaming or was it
supposed to be
something Flynn I don't know
oh sea life lover
ah whatever maybe the answer changes
every time I guess I have no no next
question
happy hearts does an octopus have of
course
correct
hmm
it's half right since Stinger Flint is
close to an octopus he's a jellyfish but
I'll allow it since you're a cool kid
while octopuses have three hearts we
humans have one and Stinger Flynn has
um I'm not sure actually but let's move
on
next question we have five senses sight
smell taste touch and
I'm so funny
wrong God damn it
screaming really how can I get every
single one of these so wrong
God
five senses sight smell taste touch and
and
oh you just made me use my fifth sense
that's enough I'll allow it
unfortunately that's all the time we
have for signs for today
go on to your second break and then
we'll start the next lesson when it's
over I can't wait teacher I just can't
wait God damn I'm cool you Fade Into the
Darkness there oh goodbye but not really
horrible hey what's up you want to join
us Punk give us some lunch money okay
uh
your money give me that
hey shut up give me your money
shut up and give me your money I don't
even know who's back there give me your
money give me well all right two
give me your money
down there how cool you are blam am I
one with you all yes please well that's
weird what am I shoving that on or in or
around
uh
attention everyone this announcement
concludes your second break okay please
return to your classes okay
all right hi it's me again bringing you
kids in one day yep
one unpopular kid
yuck one cool kid and one mean kid
welcome sit on the table to your left
where you belong so we can begin
okay that's me I'm the mean kid dude hey
kids the next lesson is health and
kindness uh-huh just like we did for
math and science it will only be a
review lesson
let's start with some common knowledge
can anyone anywhere give me an example
of an unkind person
there's an unkind person I will
cool good
perfect example good job thank you
nah and I didn't even say it this time
I will give you immense pain correct hmm
exactly giving others things without
expecting anything in return is exactly
what kindness is
this class is going to be great I can
feel it
what was that I don't know I thought I
only heard that I'm a student nobody
move while I check it out
okay goodbye
I kind of want to move
I kind of really want to move
I'm gonna move
now no God
you kidding me
all that prep all that time waiting in
the corner and that's how you screw it
up wow well done all right goodbye kids
I'm out of here forever don't snitch on
me
skipping and I'll give you some gum oh
hey wait a minute no not again oh I
actually
I don't know if you really tried that
hard
[Music]
oh
well I am curious hmm not that curious
hello
oh
okay hey hi what's up
is it time for reveal oh boy that's not
good
well that's not good I'll put it what
oh
what is
that looks like a bird I don't know if I
want to open that door
I don't like the on and off
but I'll open the door
this is a bad idea
yep bad idea bad idea bad idea
oh I get it I get it I get it I get it I
it's a lot of end
s a lot of
okay let me just look what is this
capture the birds and place them in the
nest oh
is that what I was supposed
I have no idea come here you get over
here that's weird that is very um
[Music]
take that stay there don't escape come
here you
come here come here damn it no why are
you able to put it back down what an
excruciatingly tedious thing what oh
thought something went weird with your
feet but I guess I realized that
everything about you is very weird
[Music]
got him I think this is the last one
not 100 but I think so no
why does it sound like there's a storm
of a dozen of them down there
I don't think there's any more are there
no they're all done okay but also what I
didn't realize is how does this help me
in terms of
getting away from that thing was that
actually what I was supposed to do
because if I swear if I just open this
door and it comes out and kills me like
right away I'm gonna be unbelievably
angry
oh God what
what what happened
what
what do you mean be reincarnated what
happened
what
I don't know
I don't understand
I am
confused okay
I see okay
oh you don't
you're not gonna
you're not actually gonna do yourself
oh boy
foreign
I don't know I really don't
okay
I made it oh I made something
okay good
that's a lot of cannons
I don't want to upgrade can I do I even
need to
glasses could it look really cool
where are you oh oh huh okay
rules of the cannon game game cannons
must be fired at lit buttons only one
Cannon can be fired at a time the timer
must not run out there three runs in
total
I'm sorry what
why
that's a seashell why
I'm so confused
I'm so utterly confused
I know nothing find all eight seashells
dog great
two
three
four
okay so I need to collect all of these
okay seven and
eight I think I have all eight
okay I did it can I get my prize now
wow that is a lime green card
for lime green lock
or also known as yellow
interesting
I see
[Music]
oh what what oh well I lucked out there
I did it
I think
[Music]
okay
well I did two of the rounds I'm sure
this one will now incorporate the ones
below I think
I just don't know what
[Music]
oh God this is gonna be a pain in the
ass
I don't know how much time I have to go
back down there and get back up
[Music]
oh God
remember you
I got it
yeah
geez
[Music]
I don't know how tight this time limit
is it seems like it's got a little bit
of leeway oh I'm done never mind
I did it
yay can I get a snack please I'm so
hungry slaps handshake stings great
my favorite game okay givenium oh a QR
code that's probably not good uh Lexi
and blur that out unless it's okay to
scan
who knows with these things the case
mentioned in the previous report is
moved an arm as its artificial nervous
system has worked for a split second
also if it's something cool just play it
right here as predicted GV seems to
provide identical function to human
blood when combined in cases three and
six of type 5
million circulatory systems are
ineffective the case of type 2 from the
previous report has also had a strange
physical effect GV appears to expand in
size where it is set to flow and as a
result the case has grown a number of
veins across its body and has grown
significantly in size neither growth
appears to have any kind of negative
effect besides the risk of looking
unpleasant to use we are going to
proceed with adding more cases of type 5
into the case of type 2 from the
previous reporting pursuit of more
lifelike Behavior studies on GV continue
to be performed
of course they do I bet I just bet
well that was a long way around to get
back to having a light blue key card but
I sure did it what did that do by the
way also
what was I supposed to take out of that
I know there's a light blue down the
hallway I think but I guess I gotta go
past the snail again well that's open
snail
wait that down there is open but there
is a light blue down here
and I'm sure this is important probably
or that's important I don't know
hello
[Music]
oh hello
ah there's exercise so it's best to save
your breath wait your turn or Everyone
Falls to their deaths what
dear Mommy am I okay and Claire is okay
I am okay not am I the nice jellyfish
saved us from the Big Bird and the evil
red man we are going to the jellyfish's
home
Yep they're probably dead
wait my turn or Everyone Falls to their
death
this seems like a long jump for a child
to be able to jump to also
who designed this I felt Oh I thought it
was dead
I was worried there were gaps in there
that I could fall between but
all right
this is awful
hate this I hate jumping puzzles with a
passion
it's my one weakness in an otherwise
Flawless uh assembly of skills
greatest ever
huh well I'm sure that's going to be
useful and informative is there anything
else secret that I need to know about
over here why is your platforms going
that way I don't know
doesn't make any sense I could have made
that jump
oh oh
hate jumping puzzles but God damn am I
good at video games
I don't see where everyone's falling to
their death this seems pretty fine a
little squid game-esque
do you think in Squid game season two
they're just gonna keep doing those
games more games more deaths
no idea
okay winner winner winner
made it what was I looking at over there
strucio camelus it remains unknown why
case 10 is aggressive towards all adults
conditioning also remains as ineffective
as it was in the first report what it
has been discovered however is the
reasoning behind the seemingly random
instances where case 10's eyes became
bloodshot blood who sought eyes have
also been linked to unusually high
levels of aggressiveness this Behavior
has been concluded to be different a
direct result of case 10 witnessing or
hearing the suffering of cases 10A 10B
10c d e and f despite having an abnormal
color scheme and any and all individuals
possessing childlike attributes examples
of said childlike attributes have been
described in the second update report
case is not ready for presentation again
lexian please investigate that QR code
and if it gives you a horrible virus I
am terribly sorry but your sacrifice was
worth it for the cause
[Music]
but if it's cool show everybody even if
it claimed your soul in the
discovery
there
no boy
oh
hmm
hello well that's just lovely can I eat
it
huh
oh oh hey hi would you like some cake
it's probably delicious on a normal day
you'd be standing where I am behind the
safety of this class uh-huh like you're
in a zoo watching some animals
uh-huh speaking of Zeus it's almost
assembly time where all the doors open
so we must keep this brief
look uh I'm sorry I hit you but you
gotta understand
I needed something from you that I could
only get if you were unconscious and I
was all out of said it is
she had seen me you wouldn't have
trusted me I know it
but there was one thing I didn't lie to
you about and that's me knowing why
you're here
you're here for your children
I do I'm working towards saving them if
you can't believe it
but someone else has them someone far
stronger than you and me both that
resides deep in the abyss
oh no you've gotta go there's an
elevator you know pillow Bird's walkway
take it and we'll talk again down there
yeah okay love birds walkway what do you
what you mean by that
what what mean you buy that wait
why are these all over
whoa whoa whoa
oh
no oh no hey bud how you be
wow why okay I don't wanna I don't wanna
talk to you again
okay this way
a hi hello wow you are gigantic
um okay thank you oh boy
uh oh yeah that's fine
where are you little buddy oh you're not
here are you
left or right either one whoa
okay this seems important
can I have you there
oh God come on
oh no no not like this not like this
oh wait wait a minute wait a minute wait
a minute hold on hold on wait a minute
wait a minute don't get me wait don't
get me don't give me yet not yet hold on
wait a minute I just gotta find another
way around here
I didn't quite do that right oh boy
oh boy
okay all right well left was the correct
answer I just didn't
I didn't ring around the rosie properly
I
I'm gonna have to do that whole run
again aren't I
I know I know
so I need to ring around the rosie
enough that I can hit that button and
then I'm guessing that the key card is
probably gonna drop out from there on to
the x
is that what I'm getting at
nope there's just nothing wait
wait wait
what is them what is oh
but it ran over it I was wondering if it
was going to be that thing where it
punches about it was running over it so
I gotta be there and then I think I got
a lot of distance so you're just gonna
walk right there and
Wham
[Music]
pick up Shirley hey I did it all right
I'm sure there's some kind of secret if
I go back
I mean I spent so long reincarnating so
I might as well do the due diligence to
try to see never mind
never mind hey bud
hey what's up pal that's horrifying okay
well thank you glad I did that
still not going to step under the X it's
like walking on sidewalks when there's
like sewer underneath that's big
okay good old good vinium
for growth
that really means
oh no matter what do not go down there
down there there
oh hi hello goodbye do not go down there
down where I'm going right now because
that's a really inconvenient place to
put that sign because I'm already on the
way down there
ah cool hat has been unlocked though
that's pretty cool
[Music]
I knew you'd
I sure did I sure did I sure did snitch
okay
so I gotta say there were some fun
moments it's like guarding a ban ban one
there were some fun moments but I feel
like this one was mixed in with a little
more tedium than even the last one uh I
liked what they were going for with the
quizzing I get that but it was such a
pain in the ass to restart that it
became I don't know it felt like things
were there just to be there like the
Canon puzzle didn't make any sense
thematically I know the Canon was used
before but it's like why am I on a beach
there's not even Pirates here and it
often times just felt like things were
there for there the sake of being there
there were many times when I feel like
with some Polish this could be something
very special
um but I'm not gonna fault it too much
because clearly small team trying to
make something I never fault anyone for
that so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know if you want to see
Garten of band band three whenever the
hell it comes out
and uh yeah
congrats euphoric Brothers Gecko and
fairies and all these people that are
part of this not bad not bad at all
thank you and as always I will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
foreign
[Music]